[Música]
[Aplausos]
transformar nossos privilégios em super
poder do bem
vocês já pensaram sobre isso eu vou
começar sua apresentação falando um
pouquinho explicando privilégios até a
partir de um jogo muito popular na
internet onde as pessoas se afastam a
partir de algumas perguntas sobre ser
lésbica
você já ouviu piadas homofóbicas de
colegas
se sim de um passo atrás sobre ser
mulher
você já foi qualificado como menos
produtivo porque teve que faltar ao
serviço pra cuidar de alguém doente na
família
se sim de um passo atrás sobre ser negra
você já recebeu a pergunta clássica você
trabalha aqui por estar em um local mais
refinado com a sua cor de pele
sim é um passo atrás
sua mãe já teve que escolher quais
filhos não alimentar por falta de comida
à mesa
se sim de um passo atrás o que seus
olhos não vêem não é problema seu
eu acredito que sim
transformar nossos privilégios em super
poder do bem
eu ando pensando muito sobre isso eu
entrei na fila das minorias preto e
pobre mesmo antes da concepção mulher
lésbica e mãe depois eu nasci pra não
dar certo
mas eu empreende eu sou compradora
eu sou empreendedora meu nome é william
araújo
pra mim empreender resolver problemas
esse insumo de trabalho do empreendedor
é resolver problemas e já vem com muito
insumo de fábrica gente eu chego a vida
a vida adulta phd em empreendedorismo
tive que resolver muita coisa antes de
itaqui nesse palco com vocês
o mais importante é essa nossa conversa
aqui
é um acordo de paz entre a unila minoria
ea única e privilegiada porque hoje eu
estou privilegiada
eu quero convidar vocês pra fazer esse
movimento para transformar privilégios
em super poder do bem
existia a partir do empreendedorismo eu
acendi socialmente
eu estou sob à luz desse palco hoje
porque conseguiu empreender era o único
caminho que eu tinha
as vagas de emprego não me absorviam
mesmo eu sendo a melhor aluna da minha
turma
o emprego que eu conseguia era sua
empregada não pagava nada então a
escolha que eu tive foi empreender e aí
a questão é como empreendendo como é que
eu uso essa minha origem essas minhas
minorias pra fazer a diferença hoje
porque privilégios sobre poder é sobre
poder de decisão é sobre poder social é
sobre conexões com a pessoa certa que
vai fazer tudo ir adiante e como eu
mulher pobre empreendedora faço isso eu
não me afasto das minhas origens
eu moro ainda no mesmo lugar eu entendo
o que é a miséria
eu sinto na minha carne toda vez que eu
entro no mercado de bairro na vila e uma
mãe tiram um pacotinho de queijo porque
não tem dinheiro pra pagar aquilo
e como é que o empreendedor é
privilegiada vou lidar com isso
eu tenho uma empresa 12 anos onde
fundamental a primeira coisa que um
colaborador do colaborador precisa é de
salário decente
eu vejo um monte de gente falando da
questão social e de como é bacana é
bonito hoje tu ser ter um discurso
politicamente correto e aí tu vai olhar
empresa das pessoas é salário de miséria
sabe é um desrespeito celebração a
equipe não veste a camisa gente pobre
gosta de festa de churrasco não daquela
fortinho lado da pessoa do
aniversariante do mês faz uma
churrascada pra galera tinha mete a mão
do bolso
certo auxílio estudo a meu funcionário
ele não a ele não quer estudar ele é
acomodado
a gente estuda é caro e cansativo pessoa
trabalha 10 12 horas e ainda tem que
entrar numa sala de aula e comprometer
50 e 70 por cento do seu salário no
estudo
você é privilegiado use esse privilégio
para uma coisa boa apoia o plano de
saúde cursos todos os meus colaboradores
vão ser os futuros donos da icon da
minha empresa
primeiro porque eu quero me aposentar
rápido e segundo porque quem faz o
negócio são eles
e aí o pessoal disse ah mas eu não sei
por que eles não vestem a camisa porque
a empresa é de todos todos quem gente
pra quê bolso vai lucro não vou parar de
hipocrisia né por fazer festinha decente
vão celebrar de verdade as coisas do
outro não só as nossas sobre o ser negra
versos eu empreendedora das minhas
minorias foi que eu demorei mais para
descobrir e pra agir sobre por que
durante toda a minha vida eu batia no
peito e dizia sua mulher eu sou lésbica
suporte bre mas eu não dizer eu sou
preta porque pretto estava na cara
só que quando eu não fiz isso eu deixei
de me ver e de me entender como negra e
de perceber que o racismo é a pior o
pior câncer que tem na sociedade
ele é tão institucionalizado que ele
está nos pólos de cada um de nós seja
preto seja branco
e por que eu digo isso porque muito
recentemente eu me dei conta que o meu
processo seletivo não incluir os negros
eu fazia o meu processo seletivo dentro
da universidade mais elitizada nossa
cidade
a pública apesar das cotas e lá eu não
conseguia achar negros e eu nem percebi
a eu não me dava conta
eu tive que mudar o meu processo
seletivo de tive que mudar meu mais sete
para conseguir atacar o racismo que eu
estava praticando como privilegiada
e aí eu criei cotas e graças a deus hoje
eu tenho ea primeira funcionária negra
que eu fiz conscientemente a escolha de
atacar o racismo e promover a inclusão
da minha empresa
beijo maior ela é linda maravilhosa
adoro ela então assim hoje eu sou uma
mulher empreendedora privilegiada que eu
faço com isso que o faz com o fato de
ser a minoria mulher
eu tenho uma profissão eu sou contadora
é uma profissão dura é uma profissão
masculina é uma profissão que quando eu
falo contador suspensão daquele senhor
de meia-idade uma pastinha na mão meio
careca o terno meio desorganizado né
eis o adu assim estou sempre com pressa
né
eu tenho que explicar até hoje quando eu
falo que o seu computador é que eu não
sou contadora de histórias
mas olha pra mim assim como a simpatia
alegria de dias de camiseta eu ia passar
hoje mudei de idéia
tá
mas eu sou contador aquela pessoa que
lida com tributos aquela coisa toda mas
eu fiz uma escolha como eu não podia se
aquele computador
eu não eu não concordo consigo ficar
contida naquele papel
eu escolhi ser contador e ser feliz e
isso está escrito em todas as telas de
computadores da empresa entre ser
contadores ser feliz não escolhemos ser
as duas coisas
eu criei um ambiente eu crio uma empresa
feminina eu primas uma empresa
acolhedora a minha equipe 100% mulheres
50% lésbicas 37% negras 25% mães é uma
empresa extremamente feminina e vocês
perceberam já ao entrar nesse espaço
e aí um capítulo especial de ser
privilegiada a eu bati de frente com uma
das coisas mais cruéis que acontecem com
a mulher no mercado de trabalho é a
questão ser mãe ou ser profissional
e aí começa a questão de relógio
biológico disse d'aquino daquele outro
gente não liguem pra isso eu fui mais 44
anos de uma relação lésbica de quase 20
eu contrariei tudo é muito lindo esse é
o pedro hoje ele está com um ano e
quatro meses e ele também impactou meu
olhar de empreendedora e aí o que que um
fácil como uma pessoa que tem o
privilégio de ter o poder de fazer as
escolhas dentro de um negócio
eu tive uma menina também que engravidou
a primeira coisa que eu fiz antes dela
sair em licença-maternidade aumentei o
salário dela
todo mundo tá maluca que vai aumentar
salário que ela vai sair gente filho
custa caro
caríssimo imagina só uma fralda é
horrível
o ambiente por ser feminino por ser
acolhedor
todo mundo se dispôs a criar um caixinha
fralda espontaneamente todo final de mês
ao ganhar lá e fazia o papel de juntar
um pacote de fralda pra ela eu tenho uma
sala de atendimento que é uma sala onde
a gente dorme a gente faz o que se
parece uma caverna assim bem bacana a
gente recomenda o projeto naninha a sala
do sono com espaço com cápsulas para as
crianças também dormirem porque eu não
quero que uma funcionária minha que seja
a mãe tenha que escolher entre cuidar o
filho doente ou deixar uma mesa cheia de
trabalho
se tiver essa dúvida ela pode ir pra lá
ela pode trabalhar lá pode levar o filho
dela e nós vamos estar lá para acolher a
gente não usa uniforme cada um é uma
pessoa só
cada um é único dentro do que a gente
faz
e aí se os argumentos humanistas e de
minoria que eu estou fazendo aqui pra
vocês não convencerem o suficiente têm
outros dados que corroboram com isso a
inclusão que a humanidade não fez a
inclusão da inclusão social que a
humanidade não fez a economia está
fazendo a soft skills mais procuradas
eu fui tem um estudo que diz que elas
são as desenvolvidas na maternidade
responsabilidade a produtividade as mães
produzem muito isso já é fato
isso já é dado dentro da minha empresa
tem um coeficiente do abraço como eu
disse vai lá não é pra pagar imposto
maior pode relacionar com o ser humano e
é recebido com carinho com respeito com
um chá com café com um abraço se quiser
e cada um é único isso é muito
importante eu vejo o pessoal procurando
proatividade características assim
assado e quando a pessoa entra na
empresa ela vem por um processo de
uniformização onde tu não pode fazer
isso não pode ser aqui eles queriam uma
pessoa única traz a pessoa única e
transformam ela numa massa que deprime
faz a galera viver tomando remédio
várias coisas
certo e por que eu faço isso porque o
futuro da minha profissão é humano
contabilidade a máquina pode fazer de 70
a 90 por cento do que a contabilidade
faz se eu não trabalhar com
características humanas na minha prática
eu vou deixar de existir muito rápido
inclusive a maioria dos rankings das
profissões que vou sumir contabilidade
aparece em primeiro então se tornou
humanizar vou morrer
outro dado super importante
quando a diversidade ultrapassa 30% as
empresas lucram mais não sou eu que
estou falando gente é um mercado que
está dizendo isso é certo
então se vocês não vão fazer por
humanidade
os astros privilégio bem passa por
motivos econômicos
não importa mas façam algo com os
privilégios que vocês têm muito obrigada
[Aplausos]